i'm pleased to say that joining me now
from the united states is civil rights
activist and son of martin luther king
jr
martin luther king iii and de ray
mckesson also
a civil rights activist gentlemen thank
you so much both of you for taking the
time
to speak to us today i just want to
start by asking you both and i'll start
with you deray
the the america you wake up in today and
you see a tweet half an hour ago from
the president
saying the national guard has now
arrived they are fully prepared george
floyd will not have died in vain respect
his memory i mean can you encapsulate
how you feel about what you've seen in
the last
two or three days so trump you know it's
the same
it's no surprise that he is racist and
that he is willing to use
any tool of the government to harm black
and brown people and poor people
with the police you know the police have
killed more people not less since 2014
when the protest initially began
and remember a third of all the people
killed by stranger in the united states
is actually killed by a police officer
in march and april of 2020 the police
killed at the same rate in march and
april 2020 as they did in march and
april 2019.
so even a pandemic wasn't enough to stop
the police from killing
killing people even though people were
home it was a lockdown it was
quarantined
so when i think about minneapolis i'm
mindful that uh this
is uh one of the cases that got caught
on on video
thankfully there was video so hopefully
there's some accountability there have
been 400
killing shootings by police that have
been fatal alone in 2020
there's a long road to go when we think
about the violence i'm mindful that it
was the violence of the police
that caused the unrest in the street the
protesters did not cause the violence
the police caused
violence martin luther king iii nancy
pelosi saying
it's so very very sad because the
american people in that video deray was
mentioning
saw an execution a murder right before
our very eyes it wasn't self-defense
there has to be justice
in that case for you when you look at
the reaction of the protesters on the
streets
how do you feel about about what you've
seen from the streets
well my father used to say that violence
is the language of the unheard
and so while i certainly do not
condone violence i understand
and emotionally feel for what people are
going through
because at some point it's beyond
what enough is enough i mean the the
injustice is that we see
you know my father and his team
experienced this you know 50 60 years
ago
so why have we not become a different
society
why have we not figured out how to
address
institutional racism this this is
institutional racism
it it it reeks of all of the
institutions having
these kind of problems certainly
starting with police uh but it's it's
our it's our whole society unfortunately
the tone
no one is surprised by what uh this
president
says just greatly disappointed that
he is constantly displayed no ability to
bring people together
and constantly stoking flames as opposed
to
uh coming to the conclusion that cooler
heads
will prevail justice has to occur these
these officers should be arrested should
have already been arrested
we don't it's hard to understand why
they're trying to manufacture a case
why do you need a case when the world
saw this injustice occur saw this man
killed on television and we've seen this
again and again in communities of color
and in
the african-american community in
particular um
so enough is enough and yet there has to
be some kind of institutional change
uh before we see uh something different
like sensitivity human relations
diversity and this kind of training
needs to begin in the school system in
kindergarten
and maybe we'll have a different result
at some point
but people need relief right this moment
and the kind of relief
that is needed uh is uh you know
most situations police escalate as
opposed to de-escalate
they need to learn how to de-escalate
situations
uh and a person should be protected and
served not
killed we used to apprehend suspects
without killing them
now we kill the raid and that's all
some of our police do yeah derek just
picking up on something
mr king said there the lack of
institutional change since his father's
day i mean
was it ever on the way and
donald trump has stifled any progress in
your opinion
or has it always been uh something that
hasn't progressed forward
since martin luther king jr's day
yeah you know what's so what's so
beautiful about the civil rights
movement is that they got a lot of
incredible wins right so you think about
voting you think about housing you think
about education
desegregation so uh are we in a better
place
in so many ways yeah you know you think
about the civil rights act you think the
voting rights act like
huge wins the police is one of the only
sort of spaces in
all of the civil rights work over the
last 100 years that like the structure
has pretty much remained the same it
just hasn't really moved as much and we
think about
part of the why is that the things that
we've been told work
actually have no impact so training
doesn't matter body cameras don't matter
community policing doesn't matter hiring
more black officers doesn't matter
they're really only two things that
change police behavior the first is
rules around when they can use force or
not
and the second is rules around
accountability minneapolis is a great
example of both of them
in minneapolis today chokeholds are not
banned so it is not clear that that
officer violated the full extent of the
policy because show calls aren't really
banned
obviously he put that man in a chokehold
for so long or like he restricted his
airway for so long that that's
unacceptable
it's not clear that unacceptable that
that's unacceptable based on policy
and the second when we think about
accountability in minneapolis half of
police officers who are fired are
rehired
and that's because of the way the
contract is structured and these are
things that are
fixes that we need political leaders who
are courageous enough to deal with
in minneapolis today the police chief of
mayor could ban chokeholds today they
could do it
it would take no vote no nothing they
could do it they choose not to
and that's what we see all across the
country the lack of courageous
leadership
in office martin luther king the third
do we had a republican strategist peter
lumar john earlier who said what he was
seeing in minneapolis
is not civil disobedience and peaceful
protest which is protected under the
constitution and he was making the
argument that donald trump is reacting
to local authorities pointing out they
are mainly democrats not
acting fast enough so the federal
government has to step in and looking at
donald trump's twitter he's
probably making the same argument what
do you make of that that
it's not violent protest is not the same
as civil disobedience
look again i do not
uh i i cannot
condone violence but what i will say
is if you have your foot on someone's
neck as this literally happened
constantly and you're telling people
don't push my foot away off
your neck it seems a little preposterous
i mean obviously all of this is politics
whatever donald trump is doing he's
doing for his base
um and unfortunately he isn't in a very
powerful position
and there are those who support this and
look at what he says
as the rule of law and do not have the
sensitivity to understand
the people have been pushed their backs
have been pushed up against the wall
now again i may choose a different
method a methodology to address but i
understand
what people are going through and if you
look at this this is not just black folk
in fact in minnesota it's probably a
large
part of the crowd maybe even white and
in some of the other areas around the
country because
people have the propensity to see that
which is wrong
and stand up against it now there are
many techniques that can be used
and you know again from my perspective i
hope we always can
retain some level of civility and
non-violence
but i do understand why people have been
pushed to use
uh the level that they're using um
out of frustration and again over and
over
this happens whether you talk about
walter scott where policemen shot him in
the back in
in south carolina whether you talk about
you know
uh philando uh philando uh in in in
minnesota
uh i mean these incidents just keep keep
happening you're talking about rihanna
taylor in louisville kentucky
police bust down the the woman's home
and
and
kill her while she's in her bed so you
know i'm i'm just saying that
police have to be held accountable uh
ever as brother mckissick just stated
and that is not happening so we got to
figure out how to get politicians and
others to hold
the police department's account can i
can i ask you about that that civil
civil disobedience violence um balance
and as martin luther king the third was
saying there doesn't agree with
the violence but can understand why
where do you stand on that
yeah you know it's interesting i'm
always i'm always interested in the way
that we use language to to do work in
these moments i remember violence is
harm against people
what we're seeing in minneapolis is
property damage and those
those buildings will be back that target
will be back that police department will
be back you know who won't be back
george floyd right
so when i think about violence the
violence that caused this was the
violence of the police
the violence that i've seen was seeing a
white officer put his foot on the neck
of a man
for nine minutes that that was violence
and ray can i can i just ask you your
own personal history of being involved
with protests in the black
black lives matter movement i think if
i'm if i'm right you have a case that's
coming
sometime to the supreme court which has
big ramifications for the rights to
protest i mean how do you feel about
what you might see depending on the
outcome of your own case
yeah so i you know i was in the street
in in st louis and baltimore and
charleston and a host of other cities
uh you know the case i do have a case
before the supreme court because i
officer got hit with a rock when i was
out in the street and i got sued and the
lower courts found that i could be held
civilly uh negligent for him being
hit with the rock so we are appealing to
the supreme court it's the first case
about the right to protest since the
civil rights movement
uh that has made it this far so we're
gonna hope that the supreme court hears
it
but you know people have the right to be
upset and they certainly have the right
to be
civilly disobedient and again like what
we're seeing in the street
in minneapolis is property damage it is
not violence the violence that caused
this
was the balance of the police okay uh
just a bit more time uh mr king
to you finally the
would the re-election of donald trump
i i'm assuming you would say it would
make things worse but if he wasn't to
regain office
will that fix the problem in some
respect or is is the damage so deep
that a change of president is not enough
i don't think it's just a change to
president i think it's an institutional
there are institutional changes that
have to be taken to have to take place
what we know is if donald trump
continues to operate like he's operated
and is not going to change which is
probably the case
then certainly he is not going to be the
answer
but we do need to change leadership uh
but we also need to to understand
you know victor hugo used to say
wherever there is darkness crimes will
occur but the guilty one is not merely
he who commits the crime but those who
create the darkness these institutions
in this nation many of them are creating
the darkness and they have to be
reformed and changed
and that that entails some
accountability that has to happen
and yes we do need a leadership change
as well